sticking with the coronavirus but moving
on to the u.s department of veterans
affairs which was the first federal
agency to require employees to get
coveted vaccines that was just last
month well this morning the va is
extending that requirement to cover a
wider range of workers and volunteers at
va health facilities only on cbs this
morning veterans affairs secretary
dennis mcdonough joins us now from
washington mr secretary good morning to
you
what can you tell us about the impact
that your original mandate had and what
more can you tell us about this new one
yeah thanks so much for having me tony
it's good to be with you on such an
important topic you know a couple weeks
ago we mandated about 115 000 people to
get the vaccine these are
healthcare professionals who are most
regularly in touch with veterans that's
what this is all about keeping our
veterans safe and what we've noticed is
that there's an uptick about a doubling
of the rate of vaccination among those
35 000 health care professionals of that
first wave uh getting vaccinated so
that's progressing well
based on that we've decided that we'll
start tomorrow expanding the vaccination
requirement to 245
000 additional employees about a hundred
and ten thousand of them we believe
still need the vaccination we're doing
this for a simple reason tony this is
the best way to protect our veteran
patients in the va system they've given
so much to this country they ought to
have they ought to have the confidence
that when they come into a va hospital
they're going to be safe yeah and
preparedness is part of the va mission
based on your experience mr secretary
i'm curious would you recommend a
mandate be expanded not only to the va
healthcare network but to all federal
agencies
boy i got my hands full right as it is
here with this big federal agency here
the second biggest one in the country we
have about uh 405 000 employees we're
working through to and making make sure
that each of them is safe each of them
has the vaccinations they need and most
importantly our veteran patients are
safe that's what this is all about so
i'm focused right here on us i'm sure
others are making these kinds of
decisions and thinking this through our
experience is that this is complicated
but it's very manageable it's leading to
an increase in vaccinations and we think
that's going to improve outcomes for our
veterans but the fact you guys decided
to come out and talk about it talk about
this positive experience the increase in
vaccinations some might read that as a
suggestion that you're laying the
groundwork for a broader mandate
well some may but i i'm not big in kind
of signaling i'm big big into
communicating very clearly and my
communication here is very clearly this
the most important thing each of us can
do whether you work at the va or work
somewhere else
to protect our veterans these heroes who
have given so much to our country the
most important thing you can do is get
yourself vaccinated that will protect
our veterans who have complicated health
care situations who have more
comorbidities because of the great
sacrifices they've made on behalf of
this country so if you want to protect
veterans
go get vaccinated that's the very simple
message i want to send mr secretary i
was surprised and also disappointed to
learn in preparing for this segment that
the typical va hospital is almost 50
years older than the typical private
hospital in this country and yet funding
to modernize those hospitals was left
out of the recent infrastructure bill
how will that impact your ability to
provide care
look first of all the most important
thing we have in these facilities are
the people and they're an unbelievable
team we're communicating with them all
day yesterday all day today about this
new vaccine requirement and that's going
to continue to be the strength of va our
people secondly
it was not included the 18 billion
dollars that the president asked for was
not included in the bipartisan package
passed by the senate the other night but
it is included
in the broader reconciliation package
that's now going over to the house for
consideration we're really hopeful that
they make that investment because as you
say tony uh of our facilities the the
average age of those facilities is more
than 50 years old yeah this is a private
sector the average age is about 10 years
old that's just not sustainable mr
secretary before you go just one more
question on a story that we've been
covering closely here at cbs this
morning our catherine herridge has
followed the experience of veterans who
served at a base in uzbekistan known as
k2 it's since been closed but there were
toxic toxic substances there they were
exposed to it and their doctors believe
that various cancers have followed yet
the va has denied services and those
looking to appeal have been waiting two
years or more in some cases what's being
done to help those veterans
yeah thanks so much for that tony we
announced early last week a week ago
monday that veterans who served in
uzbekistan as well as afghanistan
and iraq over the course of these last
several decades can now apply for
presumptive coverage that means that we
will presume that the
conditions they're experiencing were con
associated with their military service
they can now apply for
getting things like rhinitis cyanidus
and asthma covered and cared for at the
va that's just the start of our effort
to make sure that we're protecting the
veterans getting them the service and
the care that they've earned and that
they deserve because of what they've
done for us uzbekistan and catherine's
reporting is one example of that but
there's many many other situations that
our veterans have been in that we
believe have created problems for them
we're going to make sure that we make it
right for our veterans we started that
last week that's just the start so i
urge veterans who find themselves in
that situation please file your claim
with va please come forward we're going
to make every effort to make sure that
we're not only getting you the care that
you have earned and that you deserve and
that you need but that we're also going
to make sure that you get the benefits
that you've earned secretary mcdonough
presumptive care that is a big step we
appreciate you coming on this morning to
talk about a variety of important issues
and we'll have you back soon